thank you
[Music]
in a huge decision affecting lgbtq
rights
uh the U.S Supreme Court on Friday
carved out a significant exception to
public accommodations laws that in Most
states Bar discrimination based on
sexual orientation if you guys remember
there was a very famous case a couple
years ago about a bakery oh the cake
yeah and they're like a gay couple comes
in like we want to get a wedding cake uh
Christian Baker make my [__] take and
then Christian no against my religion
I'm not gonna have two dudes in a suit
on top of the cake hey you're lost
Bakery
yeah your financial loss
you should have gone to a Chinese Bakery
oh dude they're like the least
discriminatories they'll make cakes or
anything yeah
a cake that says like hey [__] you for
being coveted into America
don't bake that
they'll bake that they'll bake a
covid-19 cake they're like what kind of
icing do you want on them
all kinds of cakes don't have a [__]
big bat on the top centerpiece
that's what's cool about Chinese people
yeah dude he's trying to get paid man
they're like they don't give a [__]
whatever man so there's a lady named
there's a lady named Lori Smith and
she's a Colorado web designer who is
opposed to same-sex marriage personally
she challenged the state's public
accommodations law claiming that by
requiring her to serve everyone equally
the state was unconstitutionally
enlisting her and creating a message
that she opposes violating Her First
Amendment rights basically why it like
Bart
you are a web designer okay and I am a
white Supreme supremacist yeah yeah I
would like you to make an anti-asian
website okay you need to make it for me
or I'll sue you
I feel like I have a right to refuse
service like that but that's what she's
saying and many people say that that's
[__] up because it's it's actually
hurting lgbtq rights because
you can now openly discriminate against
somebody if you want to so like well
they're not discriminating they're not
going out and saying like [__] lgbtq
they're just saying my business doesn't
do that are they saying that they're
withholding their ability to express
so like if if you're not willing to make
the website if you're not willing to do
the cake then now that's a message
they're trying to get out and they're
willing to pay for the service but now
you're withholding that ability with
holding the service so I go to your
restaurant for example and like I'm like
and it says like we don't serve Trump
supporters and I'm like I'm a trump
supporter why can't I eat here right
like that kind of thing yeah like like
it kind of is baked into nice a lot of
the different
um interactions that you could have with
businesses yeah and so the Supreme Court
just said that you cannot force someone
into saying something that they don't
believe in by by their work right you
can't sue them and make and compel them
to a certain speech that they're against
that is Like Your First Amendment right
right if you're like let's say I'm a
song writer
and if the contents of your song like
what you want me to write for you does
it match then you kind of are using
forcing me to not to you to not have
freedom in my speech and make something
I don't believe also just not have
freedom in your choice and what you want
to do with your with your own work yeah
remember the [__] the police like NWA
right yeah like that you know offended
cops a lot yeah and uh and I think
everybody and it was a little bit Yeah
and but that and that was actually there
was actually formal complaints about it
too and they wanted to suppress it but
that's also them from them so it's not
like someone else hiring them like you
know like those are they're the lyrics
that they wrote yeah right so they're
exercising their freedom of speech yeah
exactly but then there's people who are
offended by that yeah and so in comes
all of this right now now Commerce is
involved yeah so um I kind of can argue
for that if there are no other means
but to go through a service to
communicate so for example right like
let's say there's no phones there's no
uh Power Company there's no way for me
to even talk to you guys directly
because I live in Alaska in a small town
right now let's say I needed to get a
message out on Facebook Messenger or
whatever and they refuse the service and
in the world there's no other option but
one way of communicating to the rest of
people and then they just stop that from
me then I can kind of see that but if
you can bake a cake yourself and make a
message if you can go to another Bakery
and get it done if you have Alternatives
you don't have to go through that one
right so then if you have these first
it's for Creative businesses right
I don't know that it's like that I think
it's just for commercial yeah but then
there's already a law that is basically
you cannot refuse the right to service
based on race or gender or whatever
that's already a law the the
the
um the circumstance here is
they don't want to write the stuff on
the birthday cake and create so they're
like I don't want to do that but they
probably would have serviced they could
sell you the case and show you the icing
yeah but I don't want to write yeah I
think I think they're zooming in a
little bit more and it's like you can't
refuse right to uh service based off of
gender whatever all that stuff that's
cool but then now if it's like
um if you have to express yourself
through that service in a specific way
that's what they have the rights talking
about so it's called the decision was
limited because because much of what
might have been contested about the
facts of the case was stipulated namely
that Mrs Smith intends to work with
couples to produce a customized story
for their websites using her words and
her original artwork and given those
facts uh Neil Gorsuch Supreme Court
Justice Trump appointee said it
qualifies for constitutional protection
you're compelling her to use her speech
and use her words and her imagery yeah
to make your point
she doesn't have to if she doesn't want
to yeah um but yeah so we'll put it
right so it's a so this this mainly
affects businesses that you there's a
creative element right it's not like you
go out to automatic doors it stays shut
because you're gay yeah it makes I mean
it makes sense to me it's like like
let's say you want a color attack got a
gaydar kind of a good business
you got a gay dog yeah I want to know
there's a gay door they're like sorry
Ryan you're gay and the white and then
why is the door again yeah the door's
gay it hates itself
you made the door game
AI is a thing yeah self-hating door
a black and black and gray tattoo
specialist and you go I want a color
tattoo they'll say no too yeah yeah it's
like that's just not their their right
their the way they express their art in
there so we're going to a sushi
restaurant in Japan and customize your
[__] yeah dude spit in your face dude I
was in Vegas and I saw Gordon Ramsay was
like made me a [__] Burger he's doing
it they won't even yelled at me they
won't even cut your pizza a specific way
like in places but then I always thought
it landed straight in the thing that we
had before where it's like hey if that's
your decision then it's the business's
loss and that's too bad for you exactly
like someone else will make that money
someone else will you know that's how I
see it and don't you want to do that
anyway don't you want to give your money
to a business that wants to do it for
you is it a forced one that doesn't
right especially for the small business
that like aligns with your values like
if that's something that matters to you
yeah that'd be cool that's right that's
that's a great way to find that guy yeah
it's like build your own work that's the
thing right there are agitators and
people who are professional sumens if
you will soon
and that's the part of their whole thing
right it's like find Center of conflict
white hot conflict and then like launch
lawsuits so go interact oh you you're
you're a Muslim right uh this doesn't
actually that's a poor example it
doesn't really happen like if you're if
you're a Muslim Baker they're not like
hey make me a gay cake Muslim Baker
because nobody has
[Laughter]
like what what the [__] did you say
under your breath what'd you [__] say
yeah that's true yeah nobody does that
but no but that's the that's the the
issue with this if you will people are
are saying
so I'm not going to be allowed to go to
places now I'm going to get openly
discriminated against and like Ryan says
they'll read that's what it sounds like
a lot of people don't read they don't
understand [__] yeah it's almost like
nothing changed it's like it just stayed
the way that it has been yeah but now
they're not you're not gonna be able to
impose on somebody yes God forbid to
give you service yeah right you can't
force somebody I will say though from
the other side right
um so Sonia Sotomayor she is the um she
has she had the dissenting argument so
anytime any of this happens they have
the the Judgment from the whoever was
the on the side of the pro and they have
the dissenting she says that Lori
Smith's objection amounts to
discrimination against the status of
same-sex couples discrimination because
of who they are speaking of the Court's
three liberal justices who voted against
it she said time and time again
businesses and other commercial entities
have claimed a constitutional right to
discriminate and time and time again
this court has courageously stood up to
those claims until today today this
court shrinks the lesson of the history
of public accommodations laws is that in
a free and Democratic Society there
could be no social castes for the
promise of freedom is an empty one if
the government is powerless to assure
that a dollar in the hands of one person
will purchase the same thing as a dollar
in the hands of another
thoughts that's not free
is it that sounds like socialism
well uh so
because basically they're saying that
regardless of what shop you're going to
it should all be the same exact thing
like you have to get the same so you
have to get the same service
I think that's the argument it's like no
matter who you are you should be able to
just go in there and get that product
from a business yeah but that's not how
it works because there's different
companies with different company
cultures and different
types of service and like you go into a
Chinese restaurant you're going to get
no service and then you get but but
they'll serve you you know what I mean
like they won't discriminate right
they'll be closing up the [__]
restaurant at like and then they'll
still stuck chairs around your [__]
table yeah they'll [__] feed you and
then they'll be like hey hurry up and
pay I've got to close the register but
they'll you'll get it yeah you know and
then another place like
French restaurant and [__] they'll
they'll probably be like you know you
can't order your dessert before and then
they'll force you to get it at the end
you know like yeah
it makes it the better
it's like when you uh it's like ritesh
like how he talks about if you're not if
you're gonna uh get your steak well done
you should die or it's like if you go to
Indian restaurant and you're like I
don't want any spice in my chicken you
should die yeah
but again like I still think it remains
and stands true that you know if these
shops don't want to serve you because
you're Asian black or whatever that's
not them it's [__] them [__] them go
somewhere it gives opportunity for
another business they will go out of
business doing that type of business
honestly yeah that's not what this does
just to be clear because of what you
said yeah this this is about that's not
what's happening usually compelling the
woman's words making her use her own
words and her own imagery to make your
point yeah it means now you just can't
force somebody to do your creative thing
but they will have to serve you they're
not going to close the door yeah they
just can't do this
if you're not Jewish I want the service
and I want you to believe what I believe
exactly that's weird people have really
twisted it to look like doors are
closing on them it's like bro the same
[__] it's the same thing
but now same rules as what's happening
now yeah now it just protects people
that have a way that they want to do
their business and now you know it's
kind of like what uh PewDiePie did with
the Fiverr thing it's like
do you remember when that happened and
it's like because Fiverr you could get
anything done so then he had he had an
anti-semitic thing done just to see if
they would do it and they did it and it
was bad on his head oh they canceled him
for it but I mean he's fine but but he
he hired some guy who's like doing web
development [__] and like from another
country I don't think he knew what oh
yeah like different language different a
lot of things right yeah and yeah for
all for all we know he saw it as like
the Indian symbol or whatever yeah but
yeah he did a full swastika and was like
[__] the Jews or something like that it
was like nuts wow but he couldn't
believe that the guy actually did it
which was the point yeah right the point
of the whole thing was that like people
will still do it you don't have to write
draw swastikas if you don't if you don't
want to if you're a [__] logo
designer you don't have to do swastics
because you don't want to not to equates
but like you know you could just do
whatever you want to do yeah and if you
could equate those things pretty similar
foreign
[Music]